when I was a kid there wasn't a lot of
spare money in our house to spend on
fancy ingredients but mum was brilliant
at what she did let me tell you so we
have really tasty hearty food great
cakes amazing puddings all made with the
freshest ingredients that's right isn't
it yes we're cooking the kind of food
mum always dished up starting with a
family favorite
steamed a pudding with a glorious
butterscotch sauce they weren't cool
desserts in those days were they no it
was pudding weddings now I'm a sieve the
flour would you I'll chop here shut up
chop those blades please there was a
favorite wasn't it amazing sir it in
okay
there's almost like an old-fashioned
dessert was never seen and everything
was sort of steam you have jam roly-poly
mm-hmm so the zest the orange makes that
really nice and fragrant sort of helps
get that richness to the suit okay
yeah brown sugar in this is such an easy
recipe yes looks fantastic on the table
and then trickle trickle in there's
something quite magical about a spoonful
of treacle you had them in there please
thank you no dude I'm crack an egg
lightly whisk it I mix that into the
milk and if I pour in the egg and the
milk will you give that it will make
some please yep thank you nice and slow
don't go too fast you see how he's just
think that it was an old-fashioned
dessert steamed pudding do you remember
me something around your knees trying to
sort of get in there yeah so you like to
lick the bowl didn't you oh it's hot now
lightly grease I was willing to help you
but not really washing up some things
never change
I think I was allergic to the soap how
does your it's just kids'll enjoy this
tonight on that delicious paper
that goes on so the secret behind the
parchment paper let's keep that nice and
tight tight yep here we are good hey
push my hand tightly cover with foil and
placing a pan of water and let it steam
for around 2 hours with a lid on are you
going to wash up God mister oh dude
goodness you like that smash mum you
handed it to me and you dropped it
come on last month forces me to break
the habit of a lifetime do you wash
enough it does that you here's how to
make an amazing butterscotch sauce to
serve with the pudding
add butter into a pan brown sugar
golden syrup and a pinch of salt and
vanilla seeds
melton combined over a medium heat
stirring the cream and simmer until
thickened that's the taste of my
childhood in a jug right there and it
will keep in the fridge for a week